[Music]
chicago schools will close for a fourth
day
on monday as teachers
refuse to return for in-person learning
forcing a group of chicago parents to
take that fight their fight to court
jackie spinner has experienced the
burden of remote learning as both a
chicago professor and a mom of three and
says canceling school
is not sustainable or responsible my
kids are not okay she writes
jackie joins us now along with chicago
dad and former educator alberto molina
jackie alberto thank you so much for
being here i wish it was on better under
better circumstances as you as you know
better than anybody else chicago schools
completely closed lori lightfoot
attempting to play hardball it seems her
kids are in private school doesn't
really affect her personally
jackie what is the impact on kids in
chicago who aren't in school and don't
know when they'll go back and there's a
standoff with the unions there
thanks for having me um well my kids are
are struggling they've struggled all
week
i wish that they could at least be
online with their teachers we're trying
to do work they're communicating with
their teachers
i'm texting some of the work that
they're doing and
they want to they want to be in school
whether it's online or in the classroom
but this this we're just not going to
have school it isn't acceptable for them
of course it's not uh alberto
the unions
refusing to come back
they were first in line for vaccinations
first in line for boosters all the
medical
protocols has been money invested in
schools yet they're still refusing
why are they
not going back to work
it just seems like a power play and
enough is enough
with all due respect to the other guests
i i'm so sorry for what her kids are
going through for all parents are going
through but enough is enough kids need
in-person learning this is the fifth
time in less than three and a half years
that our children have been denied
the opportunity to a free public school
education in person and this is going
back to the strike of october 2019 it
just seems like a power play
very inappropriate our kids are being
held hostage
and you know adults can have
disagreements but keep the kids out of
it they need their education they need
their services they need all of their
supports extracurricular activities and
we're just going to go further and
further behind
jackie i want to break down alberto's
point just a little bit here are the
demands that the union is making so this
is a showdown showdown over what uh so
they've already been vaccinated already
all of those things have already been
provided now they want negative pcr
tests
for anyone who returns to school they
want 300 testing sites which we know we
don't have enough of uh right now they
want k
special medical grade mask for all staff
and students and then the principals
need to have the authority to take
classes remote at what point jackie are
these demands i mean
what if everybody else who had a job
other than teaching under the shield of
a union could make these types of
demands who deemed themselves essential
and really are essential for kids i mean
why are we not
doing more to call out the unions for
just not working
well i think well first of all they are
working right i mean i've i've had to
pivot one of my colleges they're not
working
they're not working they're not they're
literally not working the kids are not
in the class they're not showing up 75
percent of them voted not to show up
um well i i've taught online and let me
tell you it's a lot more work than than
than teaching in the classroom but it's
no i think
i had kids on a zoom call yesterday in
my class and they're staring like
zombies there's no way they're getting
even if teachers are pedaling harder
than ever there's no way they're getting
the quality of education they get in the
classroom teachers know that you're an
educator you know that's not of course
not remote is not is not a better option
than in person
i think that um but i i also don't think
it's unrealistic to ask teachers what
measures would be appropriate for our
kids to return to school one of the
things we're not talking about here in
chicago is such our low vaccination
rates among the students themselves it's
something like 16 percent
and um you know in that jackie the
students are not affected i mean at what
point do teachers look at the side
now we know that with omicron teachers
are just as likely to get infected as
someone who is unvaccinated at this
point and kids have never been affected
by covin 19. so what's the fear factor
that are that are that that has infected
teachers where they're now saying the
kids aren't vaccinated which the parents
should get to choose so we won't go back
to the classroom like where does it end
does it ever end i mean the pediatric
icus are full of kids with covet and i
think that if you have i have three kids
who all have many of which have been
others
so
did you invite me on here to yell at me
no i expected
i mean
this is an interesting debate because
you're arguing for
some level of online um education that
the unions really aren't uh part of the
problem here and that kids need to get
vaccinated to solve it there's plenty of
kids uh that are sick that's true but
vast majority of them are not affected
by covet here's what i'm arguing for i'm
arguing for the two sides to come
together and come up with a resolution
some kind of resolution so that my kids
aren't caught in the middle of it i mean
i think alberto is right we're we're
seeing this political fight happening in
chicago it happens time and time again
and the kids get caught in the middle
between the rhetoric on both sides and
i'm tired of that i'm exhausted i'm
exhausted trying to parent my kids and
do my job i've been doing this for over
for almost two years now i want my kids
in school i want them to be safe in
school and if they're not going to be in
school i want them to be able to log on
to a computer as ugly as that is and as
hard it as it is i have an autistic kid
my autistic son does not do well with
remote learning he needs to be in the
classroom i want to be him to be in the
classroom when it's safe
alberto last word
i'm a former teacher a former principal
this is inappropriate and unacceptable i
love teachers i'm pro-teacher my
family's pro-teacher but there is a
growing resentment with the teachers
union i think it's time we need to start
having conversations about
accountability
what is the chicago public school
teachers union going to do to make up
for all of this lost learning
how are we going to hold them
accountable they're receiving their
salaries their health benefits other
benefits how are we going to start to
hold them accountable and then finally
we heard from mayor lightfoot but i'd
like to hear from our local state and
national leaders where do you stand with
the parents and families the children of
chicago public schools or with the
teachers union i'd like to know where
president biden stands on this issue
yeah unions are being exposed for what
they really are which are political
machines that protect uh their
priorities and don't necessarily put
kids and parents first at all
jackie and alberto thank you very much
for your time appreciate it
thank you thank you good luck to kids in
chicago it's amazing